Da waren die Zerböse. Vielen Dank. Kispa, das ist immer ein gutes Zeichen, wenn jemand auch einen Künstlernamen dabei hat. Eine A-K-A dabei, da weiß man schon, da kommt eine vernünftige Einsendung, wenn es nicht nur Paul ist. Nichts gegen Paul, aber wenn man einfach weiß, Kai A-K-A Kispa. Ich finde A-K-A auch so geil, weil es so selbstbewusst ist. Ja. Also known as. Es ist nicht wie das deutsche As irgendwie ein Künstlernamen oder sowas. Da ist nicht impliziert, dass es alle wissen. Aber also known as. Es klingt so passiv so, ja, man nennt mich auch. Wer einfach so, das ist so eine allgemeine Kraft, die dir diesen Namen auch gegeben hat. Nicht, ja, ich möchte, ich möchte, dass ich Fanta genannt werde. Naja, aber das ist wie alte Butterbrote mir aufs Brot schmierst. Alte, dass du mir diese alte Butter wieder aufs Brot schmierst. Aber du liebst auch Butterbrot- Brote, oder? Ich liebe, wenn man sich ein Butterbrot macht und das nochmal so richtig auf dem Brot schmiert, so richtig dir es so verteilt, das ganze Butterbrot auf dem Brot. Ich finde gut, dass diese, ah, jetzt kommen die alten Kamellen wieder. Das ist auch, es ist immer mit Essen, weil Essen hat so eine Verderblichkeit. Das stimmt. Und das ist sehr gut. Sprichwörter. Wir haben hier eine Gemeinschaftsküche, wo seit Karneval eine riesige Tüte Kamelle liegt, die niemand will und die jetzt tatsächlich von ihrem, also Kamelle sind ja eigentlich das Grösste, was es gibt, wenn du am Karneval bist und deine Hände in die Höhre rägst und die fangen willst. Aber sobald sie dann wirklich als Nahrungsmittel auf dem Tisch liegen mit Messer und Gabel, dann verfliegt ihre Magie ganz schnell. Der ist gedeckt, das gute Geschirr wurde rausgeholt, dann schön Messer, Gabel, kleiner Löffel, kleine Gabel.
Ja, richtig angeordnet. Und dann macht man dann diese, ja, oft B-Snickers oder so. Ja, B bis C. Sagen wir mal, oder das, was kostenlos in so Apotheken rumliegt, ist dann da in der B-Variante vor dir auf dem Tisch und dann denkt man, hm, weiß ich nicht, brauche ich nicht, warum habe ich das überhaupt gefangen in diesen rauen Mengen, habe jetzt fünf Edeka-Tüten davon voll und ja, ehrlich gesagt, das ist auch kein geiles Essen, also so dieses, da werden einfach harter Zucker, gefähramelle? Ich glaube schon, oder? Weil du nächstes Jahr wieder die gleichen Kamelle benutzt.
Mein liebstes Bild zu dem Thema war,
wie jemand auf dem Karneval war,
Karnevalsumzug, Kamelle wurden von den
Wägen geworfen und jemand hatte
einen Regenschirm dabei, strahlend,
der Tag, Regenschirm und hat
ihn umgedreht so hoch gehalten,
um mehr Kamelle zu fangen.
Und ich liebe diese
deutsche Effizienz auch beim Spaß
haben. So, wenn ich schon Spaß
habe, dann will ich so effektiv so viel Spaß haben, wie es geht. Nicht nur, dass die Dinger ungenießbar sind und wertlos, sondern nein, ich will mehr. Und ich denke immer so, die Leute, die daneben stehen und einfach so nichts kriegen, sie denken, okay, cool. Aber noch besser finde ich, wenn es dafür irgendwie so einen Etsy-Shop oder sowas gäbe, oder bei Instagram kriegt man so Werbung für Karnevalsoptimierungs-Multiplikationsschirm. So einen Schirm, den du so aufmachen kannst, der auch dann gut weg, also so deutsch-pagmatisch, leicht wegpackbar ist auch dann wieder, irgendwie so in den Holster, es gibt so einen eigenen Holster dafür. So ein Brustholster so an der Seite. Genau, das kannst du kaufen, Karnevalsoptimierungsfanggerät. Mit so einem eingebauten Staubsauger auch, der so wirklich aus dem gesamten Raum alles raussaugt. Und so einem kleinen Lautsprecher, der sagt, ah Kinder, der Zug ist vorbei, der Zug ist vorbei, der Leute dann wegjagt, die dann da noch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, aber das finde ich sehr gut, das ist sehr deutsch. Harald, dann müssen wir nicht
so lange bleiben, dann können wir
da in fünf Minuten die Kamelle holen, dann können
wir wieder gehen, dann sind wir schneller zu Hause.
Sehr gut, dann können wir schneller nach Hause, um schneller die Karnevalsendung zu gucken.
Und dann kommen wir aus dem Parkplatz auch
besser raus. Dann kommen wir da besser raus. Dann kommen wir nicht alle
mit einem Hammer in den Parkplatz und dann kommen wir
da schnell raus, bevor es Verstopfung geht.
Dann können wir auch heute eher ins Bett, um morgen
fit zu sein. Genau. Und der Enkel sagt so,
aber ihr habt euch so auf Karneval gefreut, also warum
genießt ihr dann den Tag, morgen habt ihr nichts
Vielen Dank. da schnell raus, bevor es Verstopfung geht. Dann können wir auch heute eher ins Bett, um morgen fit zu sein. Genau. Und der Enkel sagt so, aber ihr habt euch so auf Karneval gefreut, also warum genießt ihr dann den Tag? Morgen habt ihr nichts zu tun. Naja, doch, morgen können wir früher zum Metzger, um da früher noch die gute Wurst zu bekommen. Aber wo wollt ihr hin? Okay, aber wo endet diese Aneinanderreihung von da sind wir eher? Naja, damit wir es einen Flug früher nach dem Alle nehmen können, damit wir schön am Pool das Handtuch als Erstes da lang haben. Ihr seid Rentner, ja, aber ihr müsst doch nicht dann auch noch da eher sein. Jetzt macht doch mal dieses effizienzgestellte Denken weg. Seid ihr bescheuert? Oma und Opa, habt ihr den kompletten Stachschaden? Aber denke ich mir auch immer, ich liebe ja diese, also der Wilde Westen ist tot. Machen wir uns da bitte nichts vor. Sagt das nicht so, als wäre es eine kontroverse These. Nein, aber ich muss es jetzt auch mal sagen. Nur weil wir diese Joe Rogan-artigen Mikrofone vor uns haben, heißt das nicht, dass du jeden Satz, den du sagen musst, wie er so als kontroverse These raushandest. Machen wir uns nichts vor. Ja, also es gibt viele Leute, die nicht wollen, dass ich das sage, und ich werde dafür auch richtig Ärger kriegen für die Aussage. Shitstorm vorprogrammieren. Ja, Shitstorm vorprogrammieren, mir ist es aber egal, ich sag's jetzt einfach. Du sagst, was wir alle denken, was sich niemand traut zu sagen. Der wilde Westen ist tot. Gibt den nicht mehr. Dieses Gegenüberstehen, diese Landnahme, dieses Kämpfen gibt es nicht mehr. Das einzige, was noch bleibt, ist die Fußgängerampel, wo einfach zwei Menschen gegenüberstehen auf beiden Strassenseiten und anstatt den Revolver zu ziehen, geht es darum, wer traut sich als erstes über die Strasse zu gehen. Wir schauen mittlerweile nicht mehr nur auf die Fußgängerlichter, sondern wir schauen natürlich seitlich auf die eigentliche Ampel. Und dann, wenn die rot schlägt, geht man schon rüber. Oh, ich bin da noch viel weiter. Ja? Also im negativen Sinne, ich gehe über die Strasse, wenn kein Auto kommt. Boah, we? Das sag ich jetzt. Ja, wo willst du hin? Jetzt werf ich die Frage, nein, jetzt paddel dich zurück die Frage, wo willst du mit der ganzen gewonnenen Zeit hin? Mit diesen 16 Sekunden, die du gewinnst, was machst du mit denen am Ende des Tages? Wie du mir meine eigenen Waffen aufs Butterbrot schmierst. Wie du mir die Butter wieder aufs Brot knallst. Wie du die aufs Brot paddel. Das glaube ich jetzt nicht. Bin ich jetzt ein bisschen
überfordert. Ich berate mich kurz mit meinem Anwaltsteam.
Sechzehn Männer und Frauen in Anzügen
kommen gestochenen
Schlecht sitzen in Anzügen.
S. Oliver
Anzüge.
Nee, ähm.
Das ist ja der Moment, wo du klassisches Dominanzverhalten hast. Du sagst, ich gehe früher. Ich gehe früher raus. Aber wenn der andere wartet und du nicht, ist es ein Zeichen, als ich bin krasser als du. Ich ringe den Tiger zu Boden, du nicht. Doch, vergiss das nicht, der Mensch ist immer noch im Wilden Westen, auch wenn der Wilde Westen tot ist. Ja, aber nein, er lebt weiter in einem. Du glaubst doch nicht, dass dieses Dominanz ... Solange er in uns lebt, lebt der Wilde Westen. Er ist transformiert in andere Dinge. Ich glaube, bei mir ist es kein Dominanzverhalten. Ich habe auch keinen Blickkontakt mit den Leuten, die auf der anderen Seite der Ampel stehen, weil wir alle aufs Handy gucken und bei TikTok hängen. Machen wir uns nichts vor. Niemand guckt woanders hin. Ich habe Dominanzverhalten mit dem horten Typen, den ich bei TikTok sehe, der einen Sixpack hat und besser singen kann, lustiger ist, besser aussieht und allgemein besserer Mensch ist. Ja, aber dann sagst du, okay, du bist vielleicht ein krasserer Typ als ich, aber dafür gehe ich als erstes über die Ampel. Aber das sieht er ja nicht. Klar sieht er es, steht er ja gegenüber. Wer zieht zuerst? Siehten ja nicht. Bist du up to date mit TikTok-Trends?
Ja.
Es gibt einen, den ich nicht verstehe.
Es gibt diesen Song, dieses
I'll be the cash, you'll be the rubber band.
Das verstehe ich nicht, was das bedeutet.
Nee, das ...
Also, ich glaube, ich tapp da wieder so ein bisschen
in die Christianer Stürmer-Lyric-Falle.
Aber dieses You be the cash, I'll be the rubber band. Ich finde, also Romantik ist schwer, sind wir uns einig. Es ist wirklich nach Rilke.
Aber es ist bei dir immer, es scheitert immer an den gleichen semantischen Ideen.
Ja, es ist immer, wir vergleichen unsere Liebe oder Attraktion mit Dingen aus dem Alltag.
You be the cash, das finde ich ja schon mal gut, du bist Bargeld.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich den umgekehrten Christina Stürmer, wo gesagt, du bist ... oder Attraktionen mit Dingen aus dem Alltag. You be the cash, das finde ich ja schon mal gut.
Du bist Bargeld, jetzt haben wir natürlich den umgekehrten Christina Stürmer, wo gesagt, du bist
Geld, ich geb dich aus, es lohnt
sich nicht, haben wir hier wieder. You be the cash,
aber jetzt gehen wir in eine andere Richtung.
I'll be the rubber band.
Ich glaube, du bist das zu wörtlich immer alles.
Und ich weiß, mit Romantik tust du das jetzt eh schon ein bisschen schwer.
Ja, ich suche noch nach Worten.
Aber weil du sagst nämlich zu wörtlich, TikTok lebt ja von Wörtlichkeit, weil es gibt ja viele TikToker, die das dann ja auch Wird es nicht so gut, dass es nicht so gut, dass es nicht so gut, dass es nicht so gut, dass es nicht so gut, dass es nicht so gut, dass es nicht so gut, dass wo die das Gummiband her haben, ist eine ganz andere Frage, aber die machen es einfach sehr konkret. Du fokussierst sich auf die falschen Dinge. Die machen es einfach und du musst drüber nachdenken, über diese Metapher, weil die halten die Gegenstände an die Luft. Ich wollte gerade nur sagen, also die Frage ist sehr berechtigt. Wohin mit der Zeit? Warum immer alles effizienzgesteuert, warum alles immer so wahnsinnig schnell? Ich habe bei mir gemerkt, ich hasse Wege zu etwas hin, von etwas weg. Ich bin so, ich hasse einfach diese Zwischenräume. Mich hat mal ein Kollege gefragt auf der Arbeit, als ich noch festangestellt war, bin ich immer, als dann alle beschlossen haben, wir gehen jetzt nach Hause, es ist Feierabend und so, Werk für den Tag getan, war ich so schnell dabei, mir meine Jacke anzuziehen und zu verschwinden. Diese Zeit, wie ich meine Trinkflasche in meinen Rucksack packe, meinen Laptop einstecke, meine Jacke überziehe, wo ich das Gebäude verlassen habe, ist alles in um die acht Sekunden passiert. Und während alle noch so besprechen, ob sie vielleicht noch was trinken gehen oder noch irgendwie, was sie am Abend für Pläne haben, wann es morgen weitergeht, war ich schon zu Hause, basically. Da hat mich immer immer gefragt, warum springst du immer auf und ren weg? Und das stimmt schon, ist mir nie aufgefallen, wie krass zwangsstörungshaft das wahrscheinlich schon ist. Aber ich hasse es, meine Zeit zu vergeuden. Ich will dann lieber direkt wieder zu Hause sein. Du magst die Zwischenräume nicht. Ich mag Zwischenräume, Zwischenaktivitäten nicht. Aber sind nicht die Zwischenräume das eigentlich schöne Leben? Und da kann man jetzt lange drüber diskutieren und in in langweiligen philosophischen Fragerunden abdriften, aber du hast völlig recht, ich glaube, das ist es wirklich. Und es ist auch nicht gut. Und ich bin dann auch, was führt auch mal bei mir zu wahnsinniger Road Rage, das habe ich jetzt wieder bei mir gemerkt, wie schlimm ich im Straßenverkehr bin, neulich, da habe ich gerade wirklich ein Problem. Ich habe, glaube ich, wirklich gerade so ein Wutproblem im Straßenverkehr, auf dem Fahrrad. Ach so, auf dem Fahrrad. Ja. Ich dachte mir, weil das Problem ist, du weißt nicht genau, wie wütend andere Fahrer sind, weil jeder ist ja in seinem schallisolierten Glaskasten drin. Und du merkst, wahrscheinlich würden alle rumschreien, hätte die ganze Welt ein Cabrioli, dann würde man wahrscheinlich viel eher merken, okay, alle schreien rum. Weil Autofahren einfach das Schlimmste ist, was je erfunden wurde. Nee, ich bin auf dem Fahrrad. Und dann schreist du auf dem Fahrrad rum? Nee, aber nee, ich mache ganz schlimme Sachen. Also jetzt zum Beispiel bin ich auf dem Fahrradweg gefahren und dann kam eine Frau rausgefahren mit einem riesengroßen 5x5 Meter SUV-Panzer und wollte dann auf die sehr befahrene Strasse rauf, hat dann gemerkt, na geht nicht, weil die ist befahren, ich kann jetzt nicht drauf fahren und auf dem Fahrradweg stehen. Und ich war mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs. Ich hätte jetzt einfach, weil es war genug Platz, um das Auto hinten rumfahren können, um dann wieder auf den Fahrradweg zu fahren. Aber ich wollte ihr zeigen, dass das Verhalten nicht geht. Sehr gut. Also bin ich bis auf zwei Zentimeter an ihr Auto rangefahren, habe dann ganz stark abgebremst und sie angestarrt. Und das war mir selber danach peinlich. Aber in dem Moment war es das, was ich jetzt machen muss. Demonstratives Stehenbleiben, auch den Struggle zu zeigen. Ich kenne das auch gut. Bei mir ist es eher so bei Bahnhof und Leute stehen im Weg. Und dann, wenn jemand im Weg steht, bleibe ich auch so demonstrativ vor ihnen stehen, so als hätten die mich jetzt gerade aus einem Sprint heraus wirklich festgehalten. So als wäre das jetzt eine Riesenirritation, damit die Person denkt so, wow, okay, krass. Eigentlich wie, also ich, genau, wie Leute auf der Bühne umfallen, also so sehr schlimm oder wie Leute auf der Bühne, ich spiele für die letzte Reihe, ich spiele für die Leute auf der Rückbank, und dann bin ich so ganz eng und sie konnte ja nicht rauf auf die Strasse fahren und ich konnte da aus nicht mehr raus, dann waren wir wirklich in so einem 30 Sekunden lang, was jetzt nicht wenig, es klingt nach wenig, es ist in der Realität sehr lang Blickkontakt waren, in dem sie mega rot anlief, es war so leid und ich war so überheblich, habe ich sie einfach angestarrt, um mir zu zeigen, what the fuck are you doing, warum, fahr doch einfach nicht auf dem Fahrradweg, sie konnte aber nicht mehr zurückfahren, weil da auch ein Auto kam, aber ich war so pedantisch in der Situation. Und das habe ich jetzt,
das beobachte ich neu bei mir,
dass auch dieser, ich will keine Zwischenräume
haben,
jetzt so eine, ja so eine zwanghafte,
ich will ganz schnell nach Hause Situation
geworden ist. Klar, da kommt
noch hinzu, dass ich Autos im Straßenverkehr
hasse, am liebsten die aus der Innenstadt
verbanden will und ich sauer bin,
dass Köln so wahnsinnig fahrrad ja feindlich ist, es ist schon besser geworden, aber es ist so schlimm und ich verstehe auch nicht, warum er nicht vortrücklicher sein kann. Und ja, reg mich einfach auf und dafür kommen dann, glaube ich, zwei Dinge zusammen, warum ich dann so war. Ein anderes Beispiel, da bin ich vorbeigefahren, jemand fuhr so leicht auf dem Fahrradweg, hat seinen Fehler bemerkt, hat mich gesehen, ist wieder zurückgefahren und Und ich habe so demonstrativ den Thumbs abgegeben, mit so einem fiesen Blick, so mega geil, wie du auf dem Fahrradweg gefahren bist. Und dann, es war so, auch so übertrieben, aber dann hasse ich mich danach direkt auch wieder. Ich kenne das so gut, ich bin auch so ein Arschloch und ich frage mich auch, lernen die Leute wirklich was daraus? Also diese Frau in einem SUV, denkt die sich jetzt wirklich, ich muss mein Verhalten ändern oder ist man halt manchmal in einer dummen Situation und verklemmt sich, ich kenne das ja auch im Strassenverkehr, man biegt falsch ab, irgendwie steht falsch rum, kann nicht rangieren, muss sorry, sorry, sorry. Kann man Leuten wirklich Lektionen erteilen oder muss man einfach damit leben, dass es manchmal nicht läuft? Ja, entweder hat sie geschnallt, mir wird gerade eine Lektion erteilt, oder sie hat gedacht, ich bin auf dem Spektrum so sehr, dass ich jetzt gerade mit dieser anderen Situation nicht umgehen kann. Ich kann nicht sofort sozial adaptieren, dass sie jetzt auf dem Fahrradweg ist. Und ich fahre wie so ein, weiß nicht, also fahre ganz nah dran und bleib dann stehen. Aber ich war auch, glaube ich, ich habe leicht lethargisch auch geschaut und war dann so leicht draußen. Es könnte auch aussehen wie jemand, der dann sozial nicht damit umgehen konnte, dass der Weg versperrt ist und irritiert ist. Ja, es ist so schwierig, ob man eine Chance hat, andere Leute zu verhindern. Und das ist ja auch so dieses Ding mit Kirby Enthusiasm, mit Larry David, wo es immer wieder interessant ist, wie Leute, unterschiedliche Leute diese Serie unterschiedlich schauen, weil manche sagen, ja, Larry hat recht, natürlich, ich reg mich auch auf, was die anderen für einen Quatsch machen und die anderen sagen, ha, der sei Larry, über was der sich immer aufregt und es ist so, diese beiden Stimmen können gleichzeitig in derselben Serie, weil manche sehen diese Szene jetzt und lachen sich über dich kaputt, wie du so pedantisch und kaputt sein kannst, das zu machen. Und andere sagen, ja, völlig richtig, man muss die Leute auch zur Rechenschaft ziehen. Beides ist irgendwo eine gleiche Aktion zu Hause. Aber ich kenne das total gut. Ich versuche auch immer, möglichst durch mein eigenes Leid, anderen zu demonstrieren, was sie gerade falsch machen. Und ob das eine gesunde Art ist, Kritik zu verteilen, das steht noch aus. Wir sind wie so deutsche over-actende Schauspieler dann im Strassenverkehr. Also alle Gesten sind wahnsinnig gross, Stimme ist wahnsinnig deutlich, alles ist ganz grauenvoll und so. Ich verstehe auch, genau, man ist wie so ein Stuntfahrer, wenn so jemand leicht in den Weg kommt, dann direkt den Lenker umdrehen und dann so einen grossen Bogen fahren. Man verstärkt die Handlung des anderen so total. Alles ist riesig. Und jetzt habe ich aber auch schon Initiative ergriffen, ich arbeite an mir selber und habe jetzt mir ein Hollandrad. Weil ich hatte immer ein Rennrad und bin damit immer schwitzend und schnell durch die Stadt gefahren. Die Zeiten sind vorbei. Ich habe gemerkt, ich muss mich selber entschleunigen, Blutdruck runterfahren. Dann habe ich mir jetzt so ein Hollandrad zugelegt, so gemietet. Und da kann man ganz langsam, ich kann damit nicht besonders schnell fahren, es hat keine Gänge. Es hat Eingang. Und dann kann ich nicht besonders schnell fahren, ich kann auch nicht schnell anfahren. Und es ist super anstrengend, wenn man sehr schnell fährt. Also man hat auch diese rückgelehnte Haltung, weil in Holland ist es ja flach, man muss keinen Gang haben. Und dann hat man diese rückgelehnte Haltung, die Hände sind oben so leicht, das ist ein grosser und ausladender Lenker und alles ist so ein bisschen träge. Und dieses Fahrrad hat mich jetzt wirklich zu einem anderen Menschen gemacht. Ich meine, es war auch das Fahrrad, mit dem ich dann vor der Autofahrerin stehen geblieben bin und wo mein Road Rage jetzt piekt. Es ist ein Prozess, es ist ein Prozess. Ah, ich habe da mit dran, es ist ein Prozess. Und jetzt fahre ich auf diesem sehr langsamen Fahrrad immer durch Köln und ich bin eigentlich sehr happy damit jetzt, weil ich habe es mir jetzt ein bisschen angewöhnt, dass diese Zwischenwege, Zwischenräume eigentlich auch vielleicht legitim sind, da sind, nun mal da sind und I have to deal with them und genau, wir müssen genossen werden. Ich habe dich getroffen hier vor der Tür, kamst du entlang und es war ein ganz anderes Bild. Normalerweise kommst du hier immer gestresst an, verwuschelte Haare, Ast im Haar, Ast im Haar, irgendwie noch die Faust gereckt, den letzten Streit noch nicht ganz abgeschlossen, auch intern und dann heute kamst du ganz entspannt locker an, schwingst dich da so aus der Fahrt vom Fahrrad runter, das ist ganz toll. Aber ich kenne das total gut, ich arbeite auch gerade wieder an einer neuen Petition. Petition. Petition und hat nichts mit Füssen zu tun, aber ich, weil mein Traum ist ja immer, habe ich ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt, aber ich verstehe immer noch nicht, warum das nicht so ist. Und ich weiß auch nicht, wer kontrolliert Fahrschulen eigentlich? Wer hat da... Du meinst, es ist rechtsfreier Raum. Du meinst, es ist Wilder Westen. Nein, ich meine, wer bestimmt, was man in der Fahrschule beigebracht bekommt und was nicht. Wer ist der Cheflehrer, wer ist der Direkt? Das Bundesamt für Fahrerziehung. Das heißt auch genau so, Fahrerziehung. Das drücken wir auf alle Briefköpfe so ab. Ja, machen Sie. Herr Meierling, werden Sie bezahlt dafür, Fragen zu stellen? Nein, ich bin der Drucker. Und meine Idee ist ja, Ampel. Generell im Straßenverkehr in der Stadt geht es ja immer nur darum, wie viele Autos kommen über die Ampel. Wie viele Autos kommen in einer Grünphase über die Ampel. Und je mehr, desto besser läuft der Verkehr. Wenn da nur ganz wenige drüber kommen, dann stockt das alles vorne und hinten. Das heißt, das Ziel müsste eigentlich sein, pro Grünphase so viele Autos über die Ampel zu bringen, wie es geht. Deine weirde Petition ist, die Grünphasen länger. Nein. Alle Grünphasen länger jetzt. Grünphasen kürzer, Grünphasen länger jetzt. Das ist wie so eine Kinderidee, wie man das Leben besser macht. Ja. Pass auf, wir stehen bei roten Ampeln und wir fahren, Mama, wir fahren bei grünen Ampeln. Und deswegen ist mein Vorschlag, die Grünphasen länger zu machen. Das ist eine total geniale Idee. Nein, meine Idee ist es, dass man Leuten beibringt, und deswegen möchte ich im Kopf ansetzen, dass wenn die Ampel grün wird, fahren alle Autos gleichzeitig los. Alle Autos, die vor der Ampel stehen, fahren gleichzeitig los. Nicht erst das erste Auto, 21, 22, dann das zweite Auto, 21, 22, dann das dritte Auto. Es ist so unerträglich. Ich denke immer, wie viel mehr, es könnten locker doppelt, vielleicht sogar noch mehr Autos über eine Grünphase kommen, wenn alle, wie in der Formel 1, in der Formel 1 stehen alle Starr am Anfang und die haben alle eine Ampel. Und die schauen alle auf die Ampel
und wenn die Ampel losgeht,
dann fahren alle gleichzeitig los.
Ja, und warum kann man das im Straßenverkehr
nicht auch machen? Weil es gefährlich ist.
Es ist so dumm, alle sehen die Ampel.
Alle sehen die Ampel.
Doch, es stimmt. Ich sehe auch immer ganz hinten.
Alle sehen die Ampel und warum
die Leute schauen gar nicht auf die Ampel.
Sie schauen nur auf die Stoßstange des vorener Autos und fahren los und dann noch Handy weg und so und es ist unerträglich. Und ich will diese Person finden, die bestimmt, was in Fahrschulen gelehrt wird. Ich will die hier haben, hier am Tisch. Aber wie es immer bei deinen Punkten ist, bei deinen politischen Petitionen, du bestrafst die Geringverdiener. Die, die kein Auto haben, oder was? Das stimmt. Die profitieren, ja, das stimmt. Du machst den Straßenverkehr so ab. Ja, das stimmt. Nein, ich wollte sagen, du bestraft Leute mit einem schlecht anfahrenden Auto. Ich zum Beispiel habe jetzt kein, also ich würde mich nicht als Geringverdiener bezeichnen, das ist anmassend, aber ich habe ein Auto, mein erster Gang funktioniert nicht mehr. Der geht nicht mehr, der verbringt immer raus weiß, da wollte ich auch noch mal euch fragen, liebe Leute draußen, die mir da helfen können. Vielleicht war das jemand. Was heißt das? Du benutzt diesen Podcast nur noch als Google-Ersatz. Nee, als Anwalt meines Lebens. Übrigens, ich habe Winterreifen wechseln wann? Schreibt mir mal eine E-Mail. Erster Gang geht nicht, was tun? Was los? Nee, aber vielleicht weiß ja jemand, sagt das, fahr einfach nicht mehr.
Jedenfalls geht mein erster Gang nicht mehr und ich muss im zweiten anfahren.
Ich würde jetzt, also alle Leute hinter mir, wenn die sofort anfahren, würden die mir hinten reinfahren.
Es ist ja klar, dass man da natürlich Rücksicht nimmt auf die anderen, aber mir geht es ja erstmal nur darum, die Idee in die Köpfe der Menschen zu setzen, dass sie aufmerksam sind, sobald die Ampel grün wird, oh, ich kann jetzt schon fahren, und sobald alle fahren, fahre ich los. Nicht erst dieses, es wird grün und ich reagiere erstmal gar nicht, weil ich bin der Achte. Das kann natürlich auch sein, weil ich bin super ungeduldig im Straßenverkehr, weil ich denke mir immer so, wir könnten locker alle über dieser Ampel sein, locker, wenn wir alle nur gleichzeitig angefahren wären, und das ist das Ding, weil ich, da glaube ich, bin ich ja alleine. Ich kann ja die Leute nicht anhauen und sagen, ey, fahr los, weil das nicht in den Köpfen ist, das ist als Konzept nicht in den Köpfen. Deswegen muss ich an der Fahrschule ansetzen.
Deswegen, falls ihr Fahrlehrer, Fahrlehrerin seid, schreibt mir, woher kommt euer Lehrplan, ich bin bereit, da ein Maskottchen oder so, so ein Gecko, irgendwie so ein grüner Gecko und dann irgendwie Go bei Grün, Grün Go oder oder Grün, Gecko. Ich hab einen Flyer schon, ich hab schon was vorbereitet. Egal, aber es ist ja, also ich will ja vor, wenn ich das Go kriege. Meine Beispiele sind sehr spezifisch, direkt. Gecko, Go, Go, Gecko, so, dass dann irgendwie der ein Grüner, der so wie diese Ampel aussieht und wenn dann grün ist, dann gehen alle gleichzeitig los. Ich wette meine Partei, Grünphasphasen länger, kriegt deutlich mehr Stimmen. Weil es catchier ist, in der Praxis ist es komplett unrealisierbar, aber ich glaube, so funktioniert das doch. Aber ich finde es gut. Wir brauchen eine Petition, ich weiß nicht. Schatz, hier kam noch ein Brief vom Straßenverkehrsamt, ich mache ihn kurz auf. Du meinst vom Straßenverkehrsamt? Was ist denn? Hier kam noch ein Brief rein. Oh nein, du hast drei Punkte bekommen, weil du
nicht sofort angefahren bist, innerhalb
der ersten Sekunde bist du nicht angefahren. Was?
Ach nein, du verlierst deinen Führerscheinschatz.
Oh nein, aber ich bin
Bofrostfahrer. Du bist Bofrostfahrer,
jetzt können wir nicht mehr unsere zwei Töchter, die im Krankenhaus
liegen, besuchen. Oh nein,
aber woher kommt das denn?
Ich habe davon auch nie gehört, wurde das geändert? Das ist ein neues, Regime. Oh nein. Das heißt, wir können uns jetzt auch nicht mehr ich glaube, du musst Das ganze Essen schmilzt in meinem Wagen. Das ganze Essen schmilzt. Ich habe da Maultaschen, gefrorene Maultaschen im Wagen, die das Eis Dreierlei, Fürstpücklei, ähm, Frühlingsrollen, das schmilzt, müssen wir jetzt alles essen. Wenn das alles schmilzt und du deinen Job verlierst, dann müssen wir die neue Wohnung verkaufen, dann müssen wir eine noch kleinere Wohnung ziehen. Das müssen wir jetzt alles essen, Schatz. Also, okay, ja. Okay, wie viel Eis kannst du essen?
Okay, du kriegst es hart.
Ich dachte, gerade uns geht es sehr, sehr schlecht, aber jetzt ehrlich gesagt sympathisch.
Naja, Schatz, ich schaue eher neidisch auf uns, weil ich so, wie geil können wir das ganze Eis essen.
Naja, jede Katastrophe hat auch ein etwas Positives, weiß ich.
Probleme sind nur dornige Chancen. FDP. Wähl FDP. Naja, ich versuche es anzusetzen, also falls ihr am Hebel sitzt. Wir brauchen generell, wir machen mehr Leute, die am Hebel sitzen. Ist alles ein bisschen Stasi immer bei dir. Nee, finde ich nicht. Es ist militante Mitmenschlichkeit. Und ich finde, das kann man auch mal durchsetzen, dass du einfach sagst, warum denn nicht mal neu denken.
Nee, nee, du hast recht. Ich finde das gut. Alle sollten sofort anfahren und du hast auch einmal gesagt, dass du das mal erlebt hast. Und ich habe es einmal erlebt, so unfassbar. Seitdem kann ich das nicht aufhören, daran zu denken. Das ist nämlich das Ding, und da brauche ich jetzt vielleicht auch mal ein Vox Populi. Gibt es Leute, die schon so denken? Gibt es Leute, die schon das im Kopf haben? Ist es, was ist das Verhältnis? Gibt es schon eine Minderheit, mit der man was aufbauen kann? Oder bin ich ganz alleine? Bin ich ganz alleine? Ich habe mal den krassesten Linksabbieger erlebt. Ja? Weil der hat das nämlich hier, die dornige Probleme, ne, Probleme sind dornige Chancen.
Ist das immer noch das? Ja, ja, schornige, schornsteinige, schornsteine sind dornige Chancen. Schornige Dornsen. Jedenfalls hat er sich das zum Vorteil genutzt. Er weiss nämlich, wenn du gerade ausfährst, links abbiegst, hast du Leute, die gerade ausfahren und dir entgegenkommen. Auf die musst du warten, dann kannst du links abbiegen. Er hat das, weil die so schlecht angefahren sind, hat er sofort, als es grün wurde, aufs Gas rüttet und ist vor den Leuten, die einem entgegenkommen, links abgebogen. Und ich dachte mir, holy shit, das ist gefährlich, das ist cool, das ist Wilder Westen. Das ist nicht schlecht. Der Wilder Westen ist alive, habe ich gedacht. Der Wilder Westen existiert noch. Es gibt so viele Glitches und Bugs und Cheats im Alltag, die man nutzen muss. Du brauchst auch mal so einen Speedrun, so einen Alltag-Speedrun einfach so, wo du dann so, rechts hast du dann so die Zeiten wie bei so einem Videospiel und dann einfach so Speedrun, wer kommt am schnellsten, ist das eine Show? Ist das eine Show? Es ist, glaube ich, Galileo, es ist, glaube ich, eine existierende Show. Naja, jetzt pass doch immer ... Es ist ja die Frage im Stau stehend. Ist es schneller, die Spur zu wechseln, wenn man merkt, die andere Spur fährt gerade an und ist irgendwie schneller, oder auf der eigenen Spur zu bleiben, dann gibt es das eine Galileo-Experiment mit, die einen fahren super schnell, super gestresst, 220 auf der Autobahn, und die anderen fahren mit 130 und beide kommen gleich ans Ziel. Folgende Show, pass auf, folgende Show. Ralf Schmitz in seinem Schmitz-Mobil. Gegen Guido Kanz. Moderiert von Guido Kanz, gute Idee. Gegen Barbara Schöneberger in ihrem Schöneberger-Mobil und beide müssen vom Studio vom Hauptbahnhof zum Studio. Und wer als erstes da ist, gewinnt. Und wer schlägt den Strassenverkehr am besten. Und währenddessen, Guido Kanz redet sich den Mund fusselig, weil das Studio, das ist da, wo die Show spielt, und man wartet die ganze Zeit. Die Promis kommen am Hauptbahnhof an und müssen zum Studio fahren, ins Studio, rein, die Strasse mündet nämlich. Und wenn die Promis kommen, ist die Show vorbei. Okay, die Show dauert 15 Minuten. und währenddessen ... Was ist die Show? Christian Tramitz hat eine neue Late Night, die moderiert wird von Guido Kanz. Aber es ist Christian Tramitz Late Night. Klar. Aber es gibt noch eine Moderationsebene. Und hier ist Christian Tramitz mit seiner Late Night. Und dann kommt Christian Tramitz raus und moderiert wieder einen Gast an. Und Teil der Christian Tramits Late-Night-Show ist dieses Rennen. Zwischen Barbara Schöneberger und Guido Kanz. Gesponsert von Go Gecko, die neue Gecko-Initiative, hat uns die Autos bereitgestellt, das Schmitz-Mobil und das Schöneberger-Mobil. Und die fahren da rein, ich finde es eine geile Idee. Die lächerlich schnell anfahren. Normale Dinge des Alltags, Speedrunnen, das ist die Idee. Oder zum Beispiel Kaffeekochen, keine Ahnung, Kaffeekochen, jetzt sagen wir mal Christian Tramitz gegen Karoline Herford, beide Kaffee, drei, zwei, eins, los. Wer macht schnell einen Kaffee? Oder solche Sachen. Und ich glaube, und dann ist das Speedrunnen und dann wäre irgendwie, oh, zwölf Sekunden für den Filter, dreiss Sekunden für das Wasser. Ich glaube, das ist eine geile Show, weil die Leute zu Hause sitzen und denken, oh, die ist langsam, oh, das müsste man so, jeder nimmt doch erst den Filter und dann das und so. Ich glaube, es ist eine geile Show. Ich habe so einen Optimierungsgedanken bei allen Dingen in meinem Leben. Bei diesen Dingen, zum Beispiel Kaffeemachen, das ist ein sehr gutes Beispiel, habe ich eine unglaubliche Effizienz und ihr könnt euch so viel Zeit sparen. Ich habe diesen Speedrun-Gedanken in meinem Kopf, den will ich ja gerade loswerden. Nein, es ist glaube ich nicht super. Ja, gut, da wirst du nicht eingeladen. Niemand muss, nee, du hast das falsch verstanden. Niemand muss an dieser Sendung teilnehmen. Das war nicht die Prämisse, mit der ich ins Rennen gegangen bin. Das war jetzt mein Fehler, ich habe es falsch erklärt. Niemand muss an der Sendung teilnehmen. Sondern du wirst gefragt, also dein Management, sagen wir mal, dein Management kriegt die Anfrage, hey, habt ihr Lust bei Alltag Speedrun mitzumachen? Und dann kannst du jederzeit sagen, nein. Ich kann das absagen. Du kannst sagen, nein, und da ist auch kein böses Blut. Weil du hast am Anfang der Folge gesagt, was machst du denn mit der ganzen Zeit, die du gewonnen hast? Das ist die Hauptfrage für diese Folge, korrekt ja. Und ich möchte die ganze Zeit mein Leben speedrunnen und frage dich jetzt, ja, was mache ich denn mit der Zeit? Ich glaube, das führt zu hohem Blutdruck, der mich langsam von innen zerfrisst. Nein, weil ich glaube, das wird dich nicht gut, wenn du die ganze Zeit im Straßenverkehr oder wo auch immer alle Speedruns, weil das ist das, wo das Leben spielt. Inzwischen mein Lifehack, in Anführungszeichen, ist es, ist es, ich höre dabei jetzt zum Beispiel Podcast oder sowas oder ein Hörbuch bei diesen Dingen und habe dann immer das Gefühl, es ist keine verschwendete Lebenszeit mehr. Ich höre ja jetzt gerade etwas, was mich irgendwie weiterbringt. Weil bei mir war es nämlich der Gedanke, in diesen Zwischenräumen ist nichts zu holen für mich, um mich weiterzubilden, was auch immer zu machen und irgendwie ein besserer, clevererer, gebildeterer Mensch zu werden. Und seitdem ich da irgendwie jetzt ja, was höre, was mich... Du löst aber auch nicht das Problem. Das Problem ist ja, dass du die Verantwortung fühlst, sich ständig zu verbessern. Also ich meine, ich stimme dem Problem, aber... Das ist okay. Das Problem ist inhärent, aber das andere Problem ist dadurch gelöst. Ich würde jetzt wahrscheinlich keine Frauen mehr anfahren im Straßenverkehr. Anbremsen. Anbremsen und den gedachten Todesstoss versetzen, die Angst, blutleer, das Gesicht fließt, blut raus, weil sie Angst haben, überfahren zu werden. Das würde ich, glaube ich, nie mehr machen, weil ich das Gefühl habe, wenn ich einen Podcast höre, dann ist das keine verschwindete Lebenszeit. Und selbst wenn dann jemand Scheiße baut im Straßenverkehr, käme ich damit. Aber hörst du dann so richtig wissenschaftliche Podcasts, wo man so richtig denkt, oh, jetzt habe ich mal was weggearbeitet, oder ist es dann doch nur Comedy Bang Bang? Ja, Comedy Bang Bang. Okay. Ja. Aber ich habe, ich überlege gerade, ist das eine gute Show, so für Rocket Beans TV oder so zum Beispiel? Alltagsspeedrun finde ich super. Alltagsspeedrun. Ja, mach doch mal Alltagsspeedrun. Sowas wie Domino Day, nur ohne Dominos. Äh, das verstehe ich jetzt gar nicht. Das andere ist eine Kettenreaktion, wo Leute aufbauen müssen und so, und da geht es ja jetzt darum, was Leute schneller machen. Ist ja eher wie, wetten das. Ja.
Aber finde ich gut, zwei Leute,
eigentlich ist die Frage, wer ist der schnellere Mensch? Nicht besser, aber wer ist
der schnellere Mensch?
Ja, du musst so jeden Handgriff so perfektionieren,
so wirklich zack, zack. Eigentlich zwei Prominente
einen ganzen Abend gegeneinander,
zwei Stunden gegeneinander,
in verschiedenen, mit sehr viel Werbung,
in sehr verschiedenen
Geckau. Ich meine, wenn du schon einen Kaffee kochst. Ja, geil. Danach von Melitta. Oder Tibo, aber je nachdem. Aber ich meine, du kannst das natürlich auch dem Werbepartner anpassen. Ich habe das Gefühl, wir reden immer mehr über die Werbepartner als über die Schauidee. Eingenommen, Wagner würde jetzt sagen, wir sponsern das Ganze, dann geht es darum, wer kann am schnellsten eine Pizza machen.
Gut, das ist natürlich nicht so. Am besten eine Oper schreiben. Du bist so gebildet, wie gut, dass du so viel Zeit in deine Bildung stehst, Stefan. Das zahlt sich richtig aus. Ich bin der bessere Mensch. Ich habe wieder Lust auf Handwerk, muss ich sagen. Ich schaue gerade einige Handwerk-Videos an, ich bin ja großer Fan von ... Es geschieht mir auch so häufig. Man ist nämlich kein Fan mehr, man ist kein Fan mehr, weil das Internet zerstückelt alles, man ist so nischig Fan von irgendeinem Video von demjenigen, dessen Name mir gerade nicht einfällt. Du weißt keine Namen mehr. Ich bin ja riesen Fan von ... Fuckin! Jetzt habe ich den Namen vergessen. Von Dave Bull. Der ist auf Twitch aktiv als Japanese Printmaking und wirklich, es ist fantastisch. Der ist auf Twitch aktiv. Okay, muss ich das noch viel langsamer, muss ich sagen. Der ist auf Twitch aktiv. Unter dem Kanal Japanese Printmaking. Bei Twitch geht bei mir schon eine ganz eigene ... Stell dir vor, Bob Ross, so eine ziemlich direkte Bob-Ross-Figur. Super entspannt, weise, weisser Bart, lange Haare, sehr weise, sehr ruhig, aber unfassbar handwerklich begabt, also Zauberhände.
Und der macht eben so Prints,
also der nimmt so ein Stück Holz und
schnitzt da so ein Bild rein und das kann man
so als Druckerstempel benutzen, um
dann Bilder zu drucken.
Und der ist super,
auch sein YouTube-Kanal ganz fantastisch, der erzählt
tolle Dinge und irgendwie habe ich, schaue ich mir
von dem gerade die Videos an zum Einschlafen so ein bisschen
und irgendwie habe ich Bock auf Handwerk, irgendwie hätte ich
gern Bock, so ein Hobby-Handwerk
Vielen Dank. auch seinen YouTube-Kanal, ganz fantastisch, der erzählt tolle Dinge und irgendwie habe ich, schaue ich mir von dem gerade die Videos an zum Einschlafen so ein bisschen und irgendwie habe ich Bock auf Handwerk, irgendwie hätte ich gern Bock so ein Hobbyhandwerk zu haben, so wo du dich so richtig, weil der ist halt auch so super bescheiden, diese klassische japanische Bescheidenheit dieses Jahr, in 50 Jahren werde ich vielleicht mal ein gutes Bild machen, so du denkst dir, du machst jetzt, du bist jetzt schon ziemlich geil. Hey, du bist super. Hey, du bist schon gut. Danke. Da gibt es dann irgendwie so einen klassischen, seinen Meister, diesen super japanischen Meister, da hat er ein paar Messer geerbt von dem, hat ein paar Messer bekommen und er benutzt die aber nicht, weil er sagt, er ist noch nicht würdig, diese Messer zu benutzen, weil die sind so fein und er ist noch so ungelenkt,
dass er die brechen würde. Und er sagt,
vielleicht bin ich eines Tages gut genug,
einmal dieses Messer zu benutzen. Cut zu meinem Leben.
Ich lese, habe noch nie in meinem Leben gekocht,
lese ein Buch von Anthony Baudin,
wo drinsteht, was für ein Messer er hat,
habe gegoogelt, wie teuer das ist,
super bezahlbar,
40 Euro oder sowas. Ich kaufe mir genau das Messer und seitdem hab ich das. Hab ich viel gekocht? Nein. Aber hab ich damit eine gute Zeit? Bin ich so gut wie Anthony Baudin? Nein. Haha, aber ich hab das Messer. Ich bin das Gegenteil von dieser japanischen Bescheidenheit. Das Messer ist ja oft auch Ersatz für deine handwerklichen Fähigkeiten. All the gear, no idea. Oh, stark. Sehr gut. Gibt's schon. Aber ich weiß noch nicht genau, welches Handwerk ich meistern möchte. Vielleicht sowas so restaurieren oder so fände ich gut. So alte Bilder abkratzen, so den Dreck abkratzen oder so. Aber da kann man auch schwer mit anfangen, weil du brauchst erstmal ein altes Bild. Aber ich weiß nicht, was man gut machen kann. Also was ich total spannend finde, immer wenn ich daran vorbeikomme, manchmal gibt es so Künstlerbedarfshandeln oder halt so Spielwarenläden. Da gibt es so eine Abteilung für Modellbau. Da ist dann so Revell und da hat man aber auch diese Märklin-Eisenbahn und da hat man dann auch so Modellbaukram.
Und dann gibt es das halt auch manchmal in so Künstlerbedarfshandel für Architekturstudenten.
Oh ja, das ist auch geil.
Und das ist halt geil, weil die dann ja oft dann Modelle ja dann nachbauen müssen mit so einem kleinen Taschen, so ein kleines Messer, so Teppichmesser und dann müssen die so Holz und Kram und haben dann so spezielle Materialien und bauen das dann nach und machen dann halt mit so kleinen Ästen und Klebstoff gibt es dann halt diese Baummasse, wo du dann so, wieso, dann machst du Wattemuskram, hast du dann diesen Kleber denn speziell und dann machst du so ein paar Handmähungen und kannst dann ganz schnell so kleine Bäume, damit du das irgendwie in Perspektive setzt. Voll geil, und das finde ich super. Das wäre so mein Go-To-Handwerkshobby. Ja, dann mache ich das auch. Ich habe es noch nicht angefangen, also ich kann es dir überlassen. Oder was ich nur empfehlen kann, ist, baut eure Häuser in Lego nach. Ich kann es nur allen empfehlen. Ich glaube, Lego erfüllt auch so diesen, weil man will schon irgendwie die Hände benutzen, aber ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin völlig entfremdet von meinen Händen. Meine Hände machen teilweise Dinge und ich so, sag mal, und was macht ihr so? Ich gehe so wie bei so einem Kind, bei so einem Sohn, geht man in so einen Raum und so, und was machst du so? Und das Kind hat eigentlich gar keinen Bock, so, ich spiele Fortnite. Oh, was ist Fortnite? Deine Hände sind wie so ein pubertierender Sohn, du guckst, was sie machen, sie masturbieren. Und ich habe das Gefühl, meine Hände wollen eigentlich nicht von mir gestört werden. Ich fühle mich wie so ein Fremdkörper, die machen so ihr Ding und ich habe gar keine Ahnung mehr. Und irgendwann merke ich so, keine Ahnung, mein Sohn ist der beste Fortnite-Spieler der Welt und finanziert mir das Familienhaus. Es fällt abends auf, wenn die Fingernägel dreckig sind, dass du nicht genau weißt, was haben deine Hände den ganzen Tag gemacht. Ich habe meine Fingernägel dreckig, ich weiß nicht warum, ich habe nichts gemacht. Nichts, gar nichts gemacht. Ich war zu Hause den ganzen Tag und habe dann rickige Fingernägel. Jetzt auch, ich weiß nicht woher, das ist merkwürdig. Ja, es ist so ganz komisch. Ganz kurz. Die machen so ihr Ding und ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, ich habe meine Füße schon komplett verloren. Meine Füsse sind raus. Ich weiß. Das ist eine Beziehung, die werde ich nie wieder. Machen wir inzwischen so Irish Stepdance. Die sind komplett entfremdet. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie der aktuelle Partner von denen heißt oder wo die wohnen. Also ich bin völlig entfremdet mit den Füssen. Klar, zu Weihnachten, man sieht sich noch kurz neue Socken und so. Man kriegt eine Karte. Man kriegt eine Karte, aber das war es auch. Aber ich will nicht auch noch den Kontakt zu meinen Händen verlieren. Ich bin noch nicht bereit, die aufzugeben. Du warst auf dem besten Weg. Beide mögen dich nicht mehr, sonderlich. Nee. Keine grossen Fans, die werden nicht selten gebraucht, selten angerufen, selten irgendwie mal in Kontakt getreten. Ich glaube, ich brauche wieder ein Hobby, das ich zusammen mit meinen Händen machen kann. Wo meine Hände und ich was zusammen machen kann. Ich glaube, es ist auch so dieses, wir sitzen ja den ganzen Tag am Computer, und am Computer schaust du ja nicht auf deine Hände, die Hände sind ja, du schaust ja woanders hin, wohingegen, wenn du jetzt so was schnitzt, dann schaust du die ganze Zeit auf deine Hände und du hast den Kontakt. Oder auf das, was man schnitzt. Ja, aber die Hände sind auch dabei, so beim Monitor ist es ja nur Erweiterung deines Willens, aber du hast gar keinen Kontakt zu deinen Händen mehr. Die sind ja nur so, du schaust gar nicht mehr hin. Vielleicht muss ich wieder
mehr einfach auf meine Hände schauen.
So ist so deine Hände bei einer Gegenüberstellung.
Zehn Paar Hände
und du müsstest sagen, welche sind deine.
Ja, ich glaube schon. Wirklich? Ja, will ich erkennen.
Also die sind natürlich jetzt nicht irgendwie
komplett unterschiedlich, sondern die sind schon ähnlich.
Mal andere in dem gleichen Alter,
gleiches, also ungefähr Statur wie du und so, ungefähr so. Ja, ich glaube, ich will dich erkennen. Und ich glaube, du willst dich nicht erkennen. Ich glaube, wir sind trotzdem beide ähnlich entfremdet von unserem Körper. Aber trotzdem denkst du, du bist besser? In diesem konkreten Fähigkeit, weil ich... Obwohl es keinen Grund dafür gibt, bist du einfach besser, oder was? Erstmal sind meine Hände größersser als die der meisten, als die von 90 Prozent aller anderen Menschen, weil ich grösser bin. So, dann. Nee, nee, aber das wären auch schon Leute, die genauso gross sind wie du. Genauso gross sind wie ich. Okay, jetzt bei zehn Paaren vielleicht noch. Bei fünf sind? Bei zwölf, da würde ich aufgeben. Gino Kanz fragt dich, ob du in der Sendung bist, wo du Körperteile vergleichen musst. Du kriegst einfach mal zehn Füsse, zehn Münder und du musst gucken, welche deine sind. Das ist eine gute Show. Also meinen Mund würde ich nicht erkennen. Meine Augen, meinen Mund und meine Ohren, alles was ausser meines Sichtfeldes ist, würde ich nicht erkennen. Meine Hände würde ich sofort erkennen, glaube ich. Doch, die kenne ich. Füsse würde ich nicht erkennen, sieht man selten. Aber Hände sehe ich doch häufiger. Aber ich finde es spannend, dass du, was in den letzten Folgen sich so durchzieht bei dir, ist, du lernst, ist, erstens, du hast viel zu viel Zeit und, oh mein Gott, wie nutzt du diese Zeit? Aber, spannender finde ich noch, du entdeckst deinen Körper. Ja. Weil du bist jemand, du bist einer der unkörperlichsten Menschen, weil du bist so in deinem Geist sehr unkörperlich. Und ich finde es total toll, dass du gerade, weil du hast dich auch manchmal selber, oder ich weiß nicht mehr, ob ich dich so beleidigt habe oder du dich selber als Floating Head bezeichnet. Ja. Was wenn beide so sind. Wir sind so, wir brauchen eigentlich, eigentlich brauchen wir den Körper nicht. Nee, so wie in Futurama, wo einfach Kopf im Glas und es reicht. Die fliegen dann so rum und gucken ein bisschen, aber eigentlich ist es nur ein Hirn. Und essen so. Floating Heads, genau. Aber jetzt inzwischen merkt man so ein bisschen auch, du willst auch in deinen Körper hineingucken, du kaufst die Kameras, mit der du von außen auf dich draus gucken kannst, du hast auch plötzlich diese Aussenperspektive und du willst auf deine Hände gucken, du willst mit deinen Händen machen, du entdeckst gerade so ein bisschen deinen Körper. Auf jeden Fall, ich habe den lange genug vernachlässigt und es ist jetzt wieder so ein entschuldigendes, hey, wie lief es bei dir das letzte Jahr und so und man versucht mal so aufzuholen. Der WhatsApp-Verlauf sind nur Geburtstagsgrüße, immer, ja dazwagsgrüße. Immer, ja dazwischen, ja dazwischen. Und dann jetzt hast du dich mal gewöhnt, hey, was geht, meldest dich. Und es ist so ein skeptisches, alles okay bei dir? Ja, ja. Weil warum sollte er dich sonst melden? Oder so wie auf Facebook, wo ich es immer schön finde, wenn man eine Nachricht kriegt von so einem alten Schulfreund irgendwie, und man denkt sich, okay, was kommt jetzt irgendwie krass, noch mal irgendwie alte Liebe gestanden und so, was passiert jetzt irgendwie und dann öffnet
man die Nachricht und ist so, hey, ich wurde
gehackt, bitte nicht auf den Link klicken.
Es ist so, okay, das
haben wir uns jetzt noch zu sagen
und du hast in deinem Kopf schon durchgespielt, so
ja stimmt, die Linda, ja,
die war ja immer, ja vielleicht, Moment,
vielleicht war die immer in mich verliebt und vielleicht
jetzt gesteht sie es mir und so und dann, hey, ich wurde gehackt, das habe nicht ich gepostet. Ich bin gar nicht so, bitte nicht auf den Link klicken. Und du hast schon lange die Potenzmittel von ihr gekauft. Ja klar, wenn Linda sagt, sie hat ein Startup mit Potenzmittel, hole ich mir das natürlich. Ja, ich glaube, ich finde es total toll. Ich glaube, es ist etwas Gutes, ein guter Schritt, ein gutes nächstes Kapitel, das Florentin will. Aber dann bist du zu perfekt. Das stimmt, ich muss sagen, diese Ohrenkamera, das ist so geil, einfach. Aber wo hast du die mittlerweile schon überall gehabt? Überall, überall. Vor allem, ich habe auch mal wirklich hinter meine Küchenzeile so gefilmt und wirklich mal so in den Wasserkocher rein und so. Und ich gucke mir jetzt wirklich alles an, ich gucke einfach alles ganz genau an, so ganz, du hast so eine ganz neue Perspektive wie so eine Maus oder so, die immer so ganz nah irgendwie, ganz nah irgendwie überall rankommt, so das finde ich ganz spannend. Ich hatte natürlich auch einen Perspektivwechsel bei mir zuhause, einen super erbärmlichen Perspektivwechsel, weil mir ist, ich muss ja gerade die ganze Zeit wegen meiner Augen-OP noch Augentropfen in mein Auge machen, Tränenflüssigkeit, die muss man relativ lange dann noch nehmen, soll man so zehnmal am Tag nehmen. Die ist mir in meinem Bett runtergefallen und unter meinem Bett gerollt. Ja. Und ich habe die dann nicht runterherbekommen, weil mein Bett ist sehr, hat kaum. Ich stelle mir immer so Stefan die Sitcom vor und das ist eine komplette Folge. Das war die Bottleneck-Altestone.
Das ist so die eine komplette Folge, wo er morgens aufwacht, eine müde Hand geht so auf den Nachttisch, Ding fällt runter unter den Tisch und dann hat man so diese Flucht, wie die reinrollt und man weiss, okay, das wird die gesamte Folge. Das war so eine Bottleneck-Altestone, aber die wird dann auch irgendwie so ein Emmy, weil die so artsy ist. Ja genau, weil sich alles nur unter dem Tisch stattfindet. Das war so ein merkwürdiges Problem,
weil jetzt war die halt genau
so groß wie der Spalt in etwa
und der Spalt ist so gering,
das Bett ist super nah am Boden,
es passt genau das Wischen, es ist genau in die
Mitte gerollt und ich habe nichts
in meiner Wohnung gefunden,
was die perfekte Grösse hat, was lang genug
war, weil es genau da in der Mitte war,
aber nicht so breit, dass es noch reinpasst. Und ich fände die Verschaffung so gut, dass du alle deine alten Phasen durcharbeitest. Passt der Billard-Köhe, passt der Diabolo-Stab, passt der Pinsel von meinem Gemälde. Mein erster Versuch, exakt nämlich, mein erster Versuch waren die Drumsticks, die noch vorhören. Erster Versuch waren, also perfekt, weil ganz dünn, ganz dünn, war supergut eigentlich, aber zu klein. Ich kam nicht dahin, selbst mit meinen lächerlich langen Armen. Und du konntest sie auch nicht gut benutzen, weil du hattest nicht mehr die Fingerfertigkeit. So, waren weg. Dann bin ich wirklich zu meinem Schreibtisch gegangen und habe meinen grossen Pinsel genommen. Hat auch nicht geklappt, auch zu kurz. Und es war, und ich habe dann so lange, und ich war so wütend, da habe ich in meiner Wohnung, da habe ich gerade so ein Wutproblem, weiß ich nicht, aber ich habe da so in meiner Wohnung rumgeschrieben, weil ich das nicht, ich kam, aber was genau schreit man, also was genau schreit man, also angenommen, du musst die Szene ja schreiben. Ich habe geschrieben, was für ein Clusterfuck, was für ein Clusterfuck, was für ein merkwürdiges Problem, was mache ich denn jetzt, was mache ich denn jetzt? Was für ein merkwürdiges Problem, was mache ich denn jetzt? Was für ein merkwürdiges Problem? Was mach ich jetzt? Stefan Hochhunderkopf schreit, was für ein merkwürdiges Problem. Als Drehbuch würde dir das die Leute um die Ohren werfen. Ich weiß, aber ich rede nicht wie ein Drehbuch, ich rede wie ein Mensch. Ich habe geschrieben, was ist das für ein merkwürdiges Problem, what the fuck? Aber konntest du sehen, oder war das auch ein Problem? Du konntest, Nee, nee, ich konnte es sehen. Weil du hast es ja gebraucht... Okay. Genau, aber dann beginnt so ein ADHS-Ding auch, dann gucke ich unter das Bett, und dann sehe ich da, wie staubig das ist, unterm Bett. Guckt man selten hin und denkt mir dann, ach, das müsste ich jetzt eigentlich putzen. Ich verstehe nicht, warum dein Bett überhaupt eine Lücke hat, wenn das so dünn ist. Also, normalerweise kann man da ja irgendwas drunter lagern, unterm Bett, aber warum steht dein Bett nicht einfach direkt auf dem Boden? Warum hat es so einen ganz dünnen Schatz? Genau, es hat ganz dünne vier Füsschen. Warum? Weiß ich nicht. Weiß ich nicht, habe ich mich auch gefragt. War auch wütend auf diese Füsschen, diese kleinen Bettfüsschen. Was sind das für dumme Füsschen? Was sind das für merkwürdige Füsschen? Ach, mein Gott, mein Gott, warum muss ich mir dieses nervige Bettchen kaufen mit den Füchen! Was sind das für merkwürdige Füsschen? Mein Gott, warum muss ich mir dieses nervige Bettchen kaufen mit den Füsschen? Stefan, kannst du aber, wir müssen hier nebenan arbeiten, ja. Aber jetzt interessiert mich, wie hast du es denn am Ende rausgekriegt, dann so richtig Detective-Connan-mäßig mit so einer komplexen Struktur, mit so einem Blasebalg und so Schnüren und so? Also, ich habe dann ewig, irgendwann hatte ich so alle länglichen Gegenstände aufgereiht in meiner Wohnung stehen und geguckt, was passt denn überhaupt noch drunter und dann habe ich gefunden, von so einem Fensterreinigungsset, da gab es einen Aufsatz. Das war eine weirde Phase. Habe ich geliebt, fremde Leute Fenster zu reinigen. Seitdem darf ich mich aber manchen Leuten nicht mehr nähern, auf 50 Meter. Jetzt gab es aber so einen Teleskopaufsatz, der war ganz hinten in meiner Abstellkammer. Und den habe ich dann irgendwann rausgekramt, weil ich mit dem hochroten Kopf wütend meine Wohnung durchsucht habe. Und das konnte ich dann nehmen, das hat genau drunter gepasst, war nicht zu groß, dass ich mir ein Wendestösse. Es war so ein merkwürdiges Problem, was viel zu viel Zeit gekostet hat. Und da fang mal an, dann mit meiner neuen Gelassenheit, die ich allen meine predigen zu müssen, weil ich die ja jetzt hab mit meinem Hollandrat. Du wirst auf die Probe gestellt. Wurde ich vom lieben Gott auf die Probe gestellt. Ja. Und das war ein richtig doofes Problem, weil ich wusste ja auch, es ist jetzt, mir rennt auch die Zeit davon, mir rennt die Tränenflüssigkeit davon.
Ich habe bald keine Tränenflüssigkeit mehr. Was passiert dann? Wenn ja meine Augen, fallen die dann auseinander? Ding Dong, ja, Entschuldigung, Frau Meier, ganz kurz, ich habe vor ein paar Tagen eine Laseroperation gemacht in den Augen. Sind Sie das denn die ganze Leben an Wahnsinn? Ja, es ist gerade ein schwieriger Tag für mich. Und zwar, ich bräuchte Tränenflüssigkeit. Könnten Sie mir vielleicht kurz in die Augen weinen? Okay, kein Problem. Sie sind schon der Zweite heute, der mich das fragt. Oh wirklich? Ging das? Ich lege mich auf den Bo ... Und jetzt hier, jetzt lesen Sie folgendes Buch mir vor. Ja. Hier folgendes Buch. Ah, Jurassic Park, der Roman, okay.
Ja, der Michael Crichton liebe ich. Einfach wenn Sie kurz daraus, weil ich, ist es nicht, alles klar. Ich jetzt nur von Nachbar zu Nachbar, müsste ich mich kurz über Sie lehnen. Ja, natürlich, okay, kein Problem, ich versuche nur, dass ich das Buch gleichzeitig lesen kann. Okay. Und er schaute auf diesen ehrenhaften Riesen. Können Sie dabei die Musik nachmachen auch, während Sie lesen? Er schaute und er schaute auf diesen Riesen, Riesen und er wusste, dass er nicht umsonst gestorben war. Ende. Ah, ah, ah, danke, Ah, das tut gut. Ah, das tut gut. Ah, das tut gut. Stell dir vor, du bist nach dem Weinen, bis man so aus dem Atem. Ah, vielen Dank, Frau Meier, das tut gut. Das gibt mir noch mal eine halbe Stunde. Nee, klar, ich muss kurz setzen. Setzen Sie sich, setzen Sie sich. emotional. Das finde ich von diesem Sketch. Hat man sie weiter durch. Dann würde ich jetzt eine halbe Stunde weitersuchen, und dann, wenn ich es nicht finde, würde ich noch mal kommen, okay? Fragen Sie, Sie können mich auch einfach fragen, ob ich lange Gegenstände habe, um das unter Ihrem Bett hervorzuholen. Ach so, ja, haben Sie was? Ja, na klar. Okay. Sie lieben Billard. Und Jurassic Park. Billard, das wäre perfekt gewesen. Billard! Billard wäre perfekt gewesen, das wäre die perfekte Grösse gewesen. Unten ist es super flach, aber lang. Übrigens, da fällt mir ein, ich habe diese Woche, auch wenn das Thema jetzt langsam so ein bisschen durch ist, aber ich habe diese Woche noch mal Bock gehabt auf KI, weil ich wollte ja gucken, wie weit sind sie gerade.
Und es passt gerade gut zum Thema, weil
ich hab Chat-GBT
hab ich gesagt, gib mir mal bitte
Gags zum Thema Dinosaurier.
Gib mir mal Dinosaurier-Witze.
Weil ich bin nicht so
up-to-date, aber ich gucke immer mal wieder gerne rein
in dieses Thema, einfach um zu schauen,
wie schnell wächst es,
wie schnell läuft's. Und ich hab
einfach gesagt, komm,
ich hab Lust zu lachen, gib mir mal bitte Dinosaurier-Witze. So. Hattest du einfach Lust drauf? Und ich hatte einfach Bock drauf. Und ich fand, du kannst, also du als Humorexperte kannst ja jetzt selber einschätzen, ob du da Bock drauf hast.
Okay, wie nennt man einen Dinosaurier, der nicht aufhört zu reden?
Sprechosaurus.
Diplodocus.
Okay, vielleicht was zum Reinkommen.
Was macht ein Dinosaurier im Wald?
Er läuft rum und Brontosaurus.
Hä? Das ist wie so Anticomedy.
Das kann ich mir auch was wieder vorstellen.
Aber den finde ich gut.
Was ist der Lieblingscocktail eines Dinosauriers?
Ein Triceratops.
Okay.
Du magst kommen wir den nicht.
Okay, ich habe noch einen guten.
Das klingt vor allem, wie jemand, der schon mal gehört hat, wie ein Witz klingt.
Genau, ja, ja.
Warum haben Dinosaurier immer so kalte Füsse? Weil sie Sauri-Socks tragen. What? Ich glaube, Kinder finden das super lustig. Aber findet die AI das lustig? Stell dir mal vor, es gibt ja diese iRobot-Angst, irgendwann so krasse Maschinen, die uns dann alle überwinden. Deswegen gucke ich auch immer, wie gut sind die Gags, werden wir obsolet irgendwann und deswegen bin ich aktuell geruhigt. Stell dir mal vor, dann sind die so mega gemein und poltern uns und sowas, aber haben dann diesen Humor. Das ist ja fast noch schlimmer. Und dann lachen die sich kaputt. Dann sagt er, weil er Brontosaurus. Und die anderen Maschinen so, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, und du kannst dir mal sagen, ob du den gut findest, Achtung, was ist der Lieblingsfilm eines Dinosauriers? Jurassic Pork. I don't. Was? Ich denke mir so, das ist fast ... Lieblingsfilm des Siniseries, Jurassic Park. Ist eigentlich Fall, was der Lieblingsfilm eines Schweins. Ja, was ist das Lieblingsfilm eines Schweins? Da denke ich mir, das ist so, das klingt wie die Pointe auf einen anderen Witz, aber es klingt schon wie eine Pointe. Jurassic Park, da kann man was draus machen. Den hat er ja noch rumliegen. Ja, genau.
Komm, hau den raus.
Ich finde zum Beispiel, was ist der Lieblingsfilm eines Schweins?
Jurassic Pork?
Ja.
Finde ich gar nicht schlecht.
Jetzt auch nicht weltbewegend.
Nein, nein.
Geht die Geschichte ein.
Nicht der beste Witz der Welt.
Jetzt zählt man sich nie am Schulhof, aber es ist schon nicht so schlecht.
Ja, aber finde ich schon, oder welchen Film sollte man auf gar keinen Fall mit einem Vegetarier sehen?
Jurassic Pork.
Aber bei Google
würdest du es ja finden.
Dinosaurier-Witze.
Warum macht das nicht?
Schon nicht.
Weil Bing läuft ja jetzt auf JetGPT4.
Da habe ich noch ein bisschen Angst.
Saurisocks. Zu guter Letzt möchte ich noch eine längst tot geglaubte Rubrik, die mich nervt. Ja, wir müssen zwei Rubriken beerdigen. Die mich nervt sehr, diese Rubrik. Wir haben lange gesagt, welche Namen, die ihr kennt, passen zu dem jeweiligen Beruf. Und die Resonanz war überwältigend. Wir haben
eigentlich das dann mit Paul Molesti oder wie der
gute Kerl, der gute Mann
abgeschlossen und gesagt, nee, das geht nicht
mehr, das war es jetzt.
Ja, der des Missbrauchs angeklagt war
und Paul Molesti heißt, da haben wir
gesagt, okay, das ist zu jetzt.
Sie ist nicht vorbei.
Nein, sie ist nicht tot zu kriegen. Denn
es gibt einen, das ist vielen Dank aus dem Reddit von Gula Schanuta, vielen Dank Ich bin ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,zsammlerin, Pilzjägerin, und sie heißt Frau Pilz Hunter. Die Taz hat sie interviewt. Frau PilHunter, sie sind Pilzexpertin und seit März eine der ersten vom Bund für Umwelt und Naturschutz, in Klammern Bund, weil der Bund für Umwelt und Naturschutz Kopfschmerzen geprüften Pilz-Sachverständigen in Berlin. Zunächst mal eine ganz blöde Frage, Pilz-Hunter, ist das ein Pseudonym? Und Tamara Pilz-Hunter antwortet, lacht, in Klammern lacht, nein, das ist mein echter Name, ich bin eine geborene Hunter und mein Vater ist Engländer. Später habe ich meinen Mann geheiratet und der heißt nur mal Pilz. Ich habe mir lange keine Gedanken darüber gemacht, aber jetzt bin ich sozusagen bei einer Berufung nachgekommen, als mich beim Bund für den Pilzkurs anmelde, dachten die, ich erst, ich verarsche sie. Hallo, Frau Pilz-Hunter? Och Gott, was meinen Sie, wie viele von den Gangs wie den Tag klingt. Ja, ja, ja, Herr Doktor Pfifferling, ha, ha, ha, ha. Nein, im Ernst, ich möchte nur Pilze jagen. Aber ich glaube, es ist da inzwischen was dran. Ich glaube, Menschen sind sehr einfach zu manipulieren, sei es von ihrem eigenen Namen.
Naja, vor allem.
Dass ihnen irgendwann auffällt, ah, ich heiße Herr Pilzhandler, warum gehe ich nicht dem nach?
Ja, vor allem der erste Schritt ist ja, sie ist Pilzexpertin und heiratet Herrn Pilz.
Also allein da ist ja schon mal, da muss sie sich doch mal denken.
Also man fragt sich ja, warum genau diese Personen so von den allen Millionen auf der Welt.
Und da denkt man sich, okay, ich interessiere mich für Pilze und dann kommt plötzlich ein Herr Pilz in ihr Leben. Also man fragt sich ja, warum genau diese Personen so von den allen Millionen auf der Welt.
Und da denkt man sich, okay, ich interessiere mich für Pilze und dann kommt plötzlich ein Herr Pilz in ihr Leben und den heiratet sie dann.
Glaubst du, deswegen sind wir zusammen als Podcaster bei unseren Namen so gut gemeinsam Witze ergeben?
Ach so, Will und Hitze, das ist mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen. Witze. Finde ich eine gute Erklärung. Ich möchte noch eine zweite Rubrik zur Gabe tragen, nämlich letzte Woche habe ich gesagt, ich kriege nicht genug davon von der Berufsberatung, heute möchte ich das Ganze beerdigen. Ich gehe mal sehr schnell bei dir. Aber du bist auch schnell wieder mit so Wiederaufferstehungsory. Ja, klar, ich bin schnell wieder Lazarus. Schuld daran ist Marius. Marius schreibt, er hat in der Schule im Jobcenter in der zehnten Klasse, Jobcenter kam in der zehnten Klasse an die Schule und haben eben diese Berufsberatung gemacht. Und wie immer, bei ihm kamen zwei Berufe raus am Ende, die er vielleicht gut machen könnte.
Der erste Beruf ist Motorradmechatroniker und der
zweite Beruf ist Bananenreife
Meister.
Und an der
Stelle möchte ich den Sack
dann geschlossen sehen,
weil
der Bananenreife Meister das ist mir zu verrückt das ist mir zu verrückt, eigentlich auf der anderen Seite irgendjemand muss die Bananen ja reifen die reifen ja nicht von alleine du musst ja schon jemanden haben, der dein Auge drauf hat, der sagt, so Kinder wer bis heute Abend nicht reif ist, wird zum Smoothie gemacht, Na, komm, da geht noch mehr, das geht noch brauner.
Aber was muss man in diesen sehr, sehr unspezifischen Fragen, wie arbeiten Sie gerne mit Menschen, mögen Sie gerne Tiere, mögen Sie eher naturwissenschaftlich arbeiten oder mit Sprachen, was muss man da ankreuzen, frage ich wirklich. Aber es ist tatsächlich ...
Unserer Bananenreife Meister.
Es ist nicht so, dass diese Fragen eine Dichtigkeit haben oder eine Spezifik, dass da irgendwie dann ... Was muss man da ankreuzen, frage ich wirklich. Aber es ist tatsächlich... Um unsere Bananenreife-Meister.
Es ist nicht so, dass diese Fragen eine Dichtigkeit haben oder eine Spezifik, dass da irgendwie dann kommt, beschreiben Sie Ihre Lieblingsfrucht. Nein. Gelb, länglich, gekrümmt. Aber tatsächlich, der Bananenreifer ist ein Beruf der Lebensmittelbranche, der sich mit der Überwachung und Steuerung des Reifeprozesses von grün geernteten und verschifften Bananen im Zielland befasst. Also von irgendwoher kommen Bananen nach Deutschland und ab dann muss Marius, der Bananenreifemeister, ein Auge drauf haben. In Hamburg soll es sogar eine Ausbildungsstätte dafür geben, für Bananenreifemeisterinnen sorgen dafür, dass Bananen einen optimalen und gleichmäßigen Reifungsprozess durchlaufen und dadurch in idealer Verkaufsfarbe und bestem Geschmack in unserer Welt. Genau, dies geschieht zum Beispiel durch Begasung mit Ethen. Also da wird noch nachgeholfen beim Reifeprozess. Und wenn du dir denkst, ich glaube Banane ist ja die Nummer zwei in deutschen Supermärkten, also von der Nummerierung. Also es müssen ja wahnsinnig viele Bananen über die Ladentheke gehen jeden Tag. Also ich glaube, es ist ein wichtiger Beruf der Bananerei für Meister. Aber ich glaube, so als 17-Jähriger ist es erst mal so ein, ja ich kann mir vorstellen am Hafen oder mit Logistik, aber will ich wirklich den Rest meines Lebens Bananen reichen? Ich stelle mir gerade so vor, weil es gab so Berufsshirts, als ich im Kindergarten war, von den Klassikern, Feuerwehrmann und Polizisten. Genau, wo die Uniform so war, wo man hatte dann auf dem Shirt auch so eine Krawatte drauf und eine kleine Knarre unten und so irgendwie so ein Kugelschreiber oben drin und Sterne oben. Ich stell mir gerade das vor von einem Bananenreifemeister, Traumjob Bananenreifemeister. So eine Ethenflasche.
Eine Ethenflasche oben, sieht super gefährlich aus, daneben so ein Giftaufnäher und so. Genau, und dann so eine Farbpalette, so von grün zu gelb und wo genau ist die perfekte Farbe.
Und oben auf den Schultern so dreieinhalb Bananen.
Ja.
Also das finde ich gut, Marius, vielen Dank für diese letzte Mail, die wir zu diesem Thema ...
Was ist er jetzt geworden?
Architekt. Er hat geschrieben, ich bin Architekt.
Und deine Gebäude haben immer eine halb runde Form. Ja, wenn ich jetzt drüber nachdenke, die meisten waren wirklich gelb. Ja, wie das so läuft. Was istst du, an was denkst du, während du deine Modelle baust und so? Ich habe schon manchmal so einen richtigen Heisshunger nach so einer noch nicht ganz gelben Banane, die noch so leicht, nach so einer gewissen Härte, so eine gewisse Crunchiness. Crunchiness. Denkst du bei Lebensmitteln oft darüber nach, dass sie entweder ... Okay, ich schmeisse meinen Job hin.
... besser gereift oder hingegreift sein können? gewisse Crunchiness. Und denkst du bei Lebensmitteln oft darüber nach, dass sie entweder... Okay, ich schmeiße meinen Job hin.
... besser gereift oder Dinge gereift sein können?
Danke, mehr wollte ich gar nicht wissen.
Sie hatten ja doch recht. Entschuldige mich, ich sollte nicht mehr
so spät nachts noch meine
ehemaligen Schüler besuchen. Genau, das ist auch
eine gute Figur zum Architektürbüro.
Und sind sie glücklich?
Was, wer sind sie? Nach zehn Spars,
Häuser zu bauen. Wer hat sie reingelassen?
Sie wurden in Security, wer hat sie reingelassen? Und Sie denken nie an Bananen mal oder an Motorräder? Doch, ich denke schon manchmal an Bananen. Wer sind Sie? Sie erinnern sich an mich? Sind Sie Herr Tim vom Tims Tim-Test? Ich bin Herr Tim ganz genau, ja. Ja, ganz genau. Es hieß, Herr Tim ist seit fünf Jahren gestorben. Und du hast einen riesen Fehler gemacht, Marius. Sie sind hier reingekommen. Woher kennen Sie meinen Namen noch? Sie sind ein schlechter Architekt. Das Haus hat viel zu viele Fenster. Hier kommt jeder rein. So, wünschen euch eine schöne Woche. Macht's gut. Macht's gut, ciao. Und Augen auf bei der Berufsfrage.
Ja, bitte.
Nicht jeder muss Berufsberater werden.
Bitte, bitte, bitte.
Und nicht immer alle BWL, macht mal was Spannendes, wie zum Beispiel Bananenreifungsexpertinnen.
Ja, oder Gerber oder Glaser.
Gerber.
Macht's gut, haut rein.
Wir wünschen euch eine schöne Woche, macht's gut, bis dahin.
Tschüss. Macht's gut, hau'n, wir wünschen euch eine schöne Woche, macht's gut, bis dahin, tschüss!